when you imagine the iconic moments of
the civil rights movement
what do you see maybe the march from
selma to montgomery
lunch counter sit-ins or bus boycotts
across the country
but what about this or this
what happened in the waters of saint
augustine florida
was one of the most critical campaigns
in the movement to desegregate the us
i still have an eerie feeling when i'm
in st augustine
they did not like that idea of sharing
water the idea
that something that touched us is going
to touch them
american beaches and pools have long
been flashpoints of racial conflict in
the u.s
historically many cities prohibited
black people from stepping into public
waters
leisure is primarily a tool of
capitalism
leisure is also a tool of white
supremacy and it articulates power
in society in a certain way who has it
um who does not
who has the right to wield it and
oftentimes this plays out in public
spaces
in the north and south white people
fiercely opposed the integration of
these spaces
in some cases separate pools and beaches
for black americans were established
but they were often small far away and
dangerous
in new orleans for example the city's
designated black beach
was an area grossly polluted with sewage
from nearby fishing camps
[Music]
that unequal access to recreation is how
wadens were born
weigh-ins were a spin on the non-violent
lunch counter sit-ins
that spread quickly across the country
in the 1950s and 60s
but instead of demanding access to
businesses
wading into beaches and pools demanded
access
to leisure on one hand it's to pronounce
a sense of you see us
um and you must sort of deal with us
when you see us the other
aspect or end of of a weight in
is to invoke some sense of reaction
so since you're unwanted either by law
or by
social behaviors people are going to
react to your presence
beaches became an important site for
civil disobedience campaigns
in the 1950s and early 60s
from the shores of biloxi to chicago to
fort lauderdale
protesters gathered to demand equal
access to city waters
by the time weight-ins were organized in
saint augustine
a local movement and racial
discrimination
was already making headlines soon
the campaign to desegregate these waters
became the tipping point in a campaign
to desegregate
the entire nation
the movement in saint augustine started
with a local dentist
and naacp youth council advisor
named robert haling beginning in 1963
hailing mobilized youth in saint
augustine to take part in civil rights
sit-ins
marches and boycotts i feel it is
incumbent upon the city officials
to make sin augustine a glaring example
of democracy at work
as the demonstrations picked up so did
violence against them
hundreds of protesters were beaten and
jailed
four teenagers who conducted a sit-in
were ripped from their families and sent
to reform school
the homes of activists were also under
constant threat
a targeted shooting of hailing's home
narrowly missed his pregnant wife
and killed his dog so many houses were
shot into we knew that anytime we had
lights on in the house at night
we'll run the risk of our house being
fireballed
so my breath and i still had to keep up
with our studies when darkness came
we would take turns going into that
closet closing the door
to study and we knew if we did not go
into that particular area to study
we were going to be shot and the house
is going to be burned down
the temple of violence increased rapidly
in saint augustine the clan paraded in
the streets
unmindful of the rain ku klux klan
rallies
ramped up too at one rally hayling and
three
other activists were captured and
brutally beaten
later hailing was the one convicted for
assaulting the klansmen
after five minutes of deliberation by an
all-white jury
he was later forced to resign as an aide
to the naacp
after a grand jury accused him and other
activists
of being militant
hayling and the other activists needed a
new plan
and new allies hailing reached out to
the southern christian leadership
conference
a civil rights organization established
by martin luther king jr
at the time king's main focus was to
pass the civil rights act of 1964.
among other measures the bill aimed to
desegregate public places
but in the spring of 64 the bill had
been held up by the senate
stuck in a record-long filibuster
king knew heightened tensions back in st
augustine
made it a segregated superbomb and
believed high-profile acts of civil
disobedience
like the ones hailing organized could be
the push needed to get the civil rights
act
passed king and several sclc leaders
shifted focus to saint augustine and
began
a series of demonstrations that spring
with the sclc's help hailing's movement
gained
organizers a financial boost and high
profile supporters
jackie robinson a black baseball star
who pioneered integration of the sport
came to a st augustine rally and mary
peabody
the 72 year old mother of the governor
of massachusetts
was jailed after a saint augustine
sit-in
which put the movement in national and
international newspapers
then in a demonstration on june 11th
1964 king attempted to enter the
restaurant
at the monson motor lodge a saint
augustine hotel
owned by this man james brock
king and 17 others were barred from
entering
and arrested a week later protesters
shifted their focus to the swimming pool
at the monson motor lodge by june 18th
two white protesters checked into the
hotel
five black demonstrators were to be
their guests in the pool that day
they drove up to the hotel but they knew
they couldn't go in the front door
so they found a way in through the
hedges around the pool
as the group waded into the monson
swimming pool
other organizers including a group of 16
rabbis
invited by king formed a prayer circle
around the monsoon to join in the civil
rights demonstration
with the rabbis outside king marching
down the street with others
and the weighed in at the pool the
demonstration was designed to grab
attention
at first james brock the hotel owner
tried to use a cleaning pole to get the
swimmers out
but when that didn't work brock tried
something else
he came out with a bottle of
hydrochloric acid
a corrosive pool cleaning chemical and
threw the acid toward the protesters in
the pool
to drive them out mimi jones
one of the protesters in the pool that
day recalled her experience in a 2017
interview and all of a sudden
i the water in front of my face
started to bubble up like volcanic
like a volcanic eruption i could barely
breathe
it was entering my nose and my eyes it
was just
very frightening and terrified
because i really didn't see him coming
soon after
a fully clothed police officer jumped
into the pool
to arrest us to
usher us out of the pool and there were
other policemen there waiting for us
and carted us off to jail the goal of
the waden
was to make the news and photographers
captured
every moment
our whole foreign policy and everything
else go to hell over this yesterday in
the swimming pool sat augustine i
started
pouring acid in the pool the very next
day
after a 60-day filibuster the u.s senate
passed the civil rights
act of 1964 making way for it to get
signed into law by the president
as the nation waited for the bill to get
signed the saint augustine wadens
continued on the beaches
day after day dozens of black and white
demonstrators
showed up to the shore and were met with
brutality from white supremacists
we went to saint augustine beach and
then
all of a sudden they started hitting us
and just punching
anybody who got in the way and i was one
of the ones who was punched
my nose was broken the violence peaked
on june 25th when 75 people
peacefully entered the water highway
patrol was sent in to keep the peace
but violence quickly broke out and they
arrested both black
and white demonstrators notice the speed
at which the action develops
and the need for officers to pursue the
attackers the demonstrations continue
the fighting continued the bullying
continued
and it wasn't just about us and
integrating that beach
we knew we knew about the bigger picture
later that night
hundreds of white supremacists rallied
in saint augustine and attacked civil
rights protesters on a march
the clash led to 19 black people being
hospitalized
with many more injured on the night of
june 25th
1964 the fuse burned down
and the racial bomb exploded
but they tell me that i don't even have
the right to fight to protect the white
race
a week later on july 2 the civil rights
act of
1964 was signed into law
congress passes the most sweeping civil
rights bill ever to be written into the
law
the civil rights act of 1964 is signed
at the white house by president johnson
to back what he calls a turning point in
history
this moment was monumental but in the
years that followed
weigh-ins continued cities used
different strategies to keep their hold
on segregation
for public beaches and pools that meant
many whites only signs
were simply replaced with private club
signs and
high fees to enter and as white people
started fleeing cities for the suburbs
local governments
neglected many urban pools and
eventually
shut them down as for saint augustine
the passing of the civil rights act
didn't change the minds of white
residents there either in the years that
followed
dr haling left saint augustine he could
no longer make a living in the city
or feel safe there saint augustine is
still roughly
[Music]
the saint augustine that i remember from
the 60s u.s beaches and pools
remained battlegrounds today in
pennsylvania
black and brown children were kicked out
of their rented pool space
because management feared it could
change the complexion of the private
club
in texas white residents called the
police on black teens trying to enjoy
the neighborhood pool
and in north carolina a white hotel
employee called the police on a black
family
using the pool during their stay all of
what happened in the 60s
you see some of it come back it's like
deja vu i asked you to leave politely
simple as that and i heard this lady she
was like what are all these black kids
doing here she's like i'm scared they
might do something to my child
[Music]
you're not having any
[Music]
here
[Music]
hi everyone thanks for watching this
episode of missing chapter
if you want to know more about st
augustine and the waydens
we have something special for you the
first ever missing chapter
in podcast form we dive deeper into
cynthia's experience as a local activist
and speak to a protester who is at the
monson motor lodge pool
you can find a link to that podcast in
the description below